I think what makes this one's different
is just basically a level of behaviors
and standards that everyone's required
to meet its a real clear roadmap the
players that come in from other teams or
young draftees how they get a game what
they need to do from a training
perspective but also having it carry
themselves outside the footy club a
really close-knit group a lot of players
from other states or a family orientated
club that's what makes everyone quite
close and helps build the trust amongst
a group and that's where I think we get
that edge amongst other times it's not
just what we do on the field that
contributes to our performance
everything that is and nutrition is so
important
my name is Elise Cameron and the
dietician for the Sydney Swans I manage
everything from the matchday nutrition
to the food when the boys are on the
road the demands of AFL it's such a
unique sport to work with the sport is
largely endurance based but there's such
a huge power and strength component to
it so recovery after training in games
is critical in preparation for the next
training session there's quite a
significant amount of oxidative damage
done when you're running that much the
boys have different favourites it
depends on their palates really but
generally the go energy bars are
accepted really well by most of the
players they like the fact that they're
not in sort of an artificial chocolate
or caramel flavor there they're real
fruit flavor the importance of banned
substance testing for us is critical the
SAS brand really aligns with our needs
well in that area in terms of we can
trust the products and we know that
they're triple tested the most important
factors for success to me would be broke
up into two areas obviously individually
and as a team for me personally I think
setting high standards and training to
high standards continually day-in
day-out
whether it's nutrition whether it's
training whether it's skills whether
it's pushing my teammates along and then
as a team focus having that belief
within the group to to work for each
other care for each other and do
anything you can to be the best possible
team
[Music]